[Music]
birthdays are fun and there's nothing
like getting a toy that becomes your
favorite for years to come
but not all toys work that way these are
the toys no kid wants to receive on
their birthday and we've set child
protection services we'll have a thing
or two to say about a couple of these -
especially the last one give this video
a thumbs up and hit the subscribe button
to never miss another video again now
let's check out 20 toys no kid wants to
receive on their birthday Beetlejuice
Living Dead Dolls if you're scared of
dolls you should probably just skip a
couple of seconds ahead because this toy
will probably give you plenty of
nightmares or just close your eyes and
pretend we're just showing you a puppy
the terrifying doll
is also the reason why it definitely
shouldn't be given as a present
especially to younger kids Beetlejuice
might be a comedy fantasy movie but
there's nothing funny about this
Beetlejuice doll can you imagine waking
up in the middle of the night and seeing
that doll stare at you with those creepy
eyes no thank you
we think we'll pass on this present and
beat that kids would - wait until you
see some of the craziest Japanese toys
ever Dora occupied you can open your
eyes now but only if you're ready to see
something that definitely wasn't meant
to be a kids present yes it's Dora the
Explorer and what looks like to be water
when you press the buttons you move her
around but that's not what's weird about
this toy the shape of it is too
inappropriate for kids and we don't
think any child would see or play with
something like this it's not the first
time kids toys became totally
inappropriate and it's definitely not
the last we'll let this store the
Explorer livesafe in a toy box far far
away from any kids The Punisher
this shapeshifter toy definitely took a
few wrong turns and grew a few
questionable limbs in the process we
probably don't have to point out why we
think this is one of those toys that
should be put back on the Shelf his name
is the Punisher and we don't really want
to know how he's punishing people and
why that
way too much information for children
and to be honest it's totally
inappropriate but this is not the only
time the toy makers decided to put a
little bit of humor in the toy these
things happen so often we're pretty sure
they're not an accident
Wolverine's squeaky hammer here's a
Wolverine squeaky hammer squeak Amber's
are in general annoying to almost every
parent so we're sure there are very few
children who would get this as a
birthday present in the first place but
this Wolverine hammer has a weird hole
where you can blow it up can you see it
yep that's right
whoever designed this thought it was
appropriate to put the blow-up hole on
such questionable part of Wolverines
body do you think this was just a
coincidence or did the designers know
what was actually happening we say they
probably knew and did it for laughs
straightjacket this toy belongs to a
company called control toys that created
a line of educational toys but kept kids
in control it definitely sounds like
something no kid would ever want right
this straitjacket is exactly what it
looks like a kid version of the jacket
not a lot of people were able to escape
from unless it involved dislocating a
few shoulders but luckily this toy is
totally fake it was created as part of
the super nanny show to see if they
would capture the attention of parents
but it's still one of those toys no kid
would ever want to receive on their
birthday happy heavy ball along with the
straightjacket toy this toy was also
created as a part of the super nanny
show there really are better ways to
discipline your kids and we can't
imagine any child wanting to receive a
present like this
can we actually imagine painting your
kid with one leg to make sure they don't
go away we have a feeling protection
services would have a thing or two to
say about a toy like this besides is it
really a present if the toy involves
disciplining a child and controlling
their movement
we're definitely glad this toy was just
too fake products because there's no
doubt some parents would actually buy it
roadkill cats again you might want to
close your eyes if you don't want to see
any imitations of dead animals as a toy
we have to admit that this one is
definitely not pretty this Japanese toy
is just what you think it is a roadkill
cat toy complete with guts spilled out
on the floor we all know Japan is crazy
when it comes to kid toys but maybe we
should stop it all with roadkill items
that were meant for child's play
we're pretty sure kids would have
nightmares if they ever saw this because
we definitely don't feel like this would
be an appropriate toy bake dog mustache
okay we have to admit that this one is
kind of funny but we're pretty sure a
child wouldn't know what to do with this
toy mustache items are still popular but
perhaps this is a product that would be
more appreciated by adults if you ever
wanted to put a mustache on a dog this
is something you absolutely have to get
although we're pretty sure it won't take
long before the dog would spit out the
toy and never try to put it on its mouth
again the dog mustache is a short-lived
toy and definitely something no kid will
ever want to play with for longer than a
couple of seconds
Pachi Pachi clappy we're not even sure
what this thing is we just know it's a
Japanese toy so by a default that
probably already makes it weird
we're not sure what someone else would
do with this toy when you press it the
toy was supposed to clap and that's
pretty much all it does we're sure
there's at least one child out there
that might find this entertaining for a
couple of minutes but eventually
completely give up on this toy what do
you say is it a yay or nay for the Pachi
Pachi clappy toy plus flea if you saw
our other videos on a weird kid toys you
probably know that there are some pretty
crazy plush toys out there but what
what's going on in the toy makers heads
when they came up with this plush flea
we're pretty sure most kids are afraid
of insects anyways but there are a rare
few that would probably cuddle with this
weird flea creature at night no matter
how fluffy it is we'll give this one a
pass and we bet there are plenty of kids
out there that would do exactly the same
besides there's really nothing endearing
about these at all and if anything it
should be taught personal hygiene to
avoid insects like these the tochi's
dissection animals these tiny animal
toys are nothing special on the first
site but maybe that's why most people
should just give them one look and move
along if you want to buy your kids one
of these we can already tell you they
probably won't be impressed these toys
allow you to dissect an animal piece by
piece
teaches kids Anatomy but is it actually
a good playing toy we have a feeling
this wouldn't go down well with the
sensitive children that love animals
then again kids these days are into some
weird stuff what do you think about this
educational animal dissecting toy carp
person okay there is only one word that
could describe this weird Japanese toy
and also pretty weird too we honestly
can't imagine any child wanting to
receive this toy on their birthday and
if they did they'd probably end up
having nightmares for the entire week
after we're not really sure why this
thing was invented in the first place
but we have a feeling there are very few
people that would want this toy around
who knows maybe there are a few kids out
there that absolutely love fish to the
point where they want to be one the
lucky poo we're telling you the
obsession with poo toys got a little bit
out of hand we're not sure what we
prefer if we flush or this strange poo
toy it might be cuddly and it might be
even fluffy but this is one of the
weirdest things ever we all know kids
that love the poop emoji and those who
even had a poop themed birthday party
because anyone really want to snuggle up
to a clue cushion that looks nothing
like the emoji this toy is called the
lucky poo indicating that it's pretty
happy being out and about stripper LEGO
sets yes
this actually exists we feel like
parents might have a thing or two to say
about this at Lego playset that features
pole dancing in a nightclub we feel like
this one might just be a little bit too
inappropriate for kids to play with
afterall would a child even know what
the Lego money is for if they've never
seen a club like this although this of
course isn't an official Lego set it's
totally custom made and available for
purchase for a whopping two hundred and
seventy-five dollars there are
definitely way better birthday presents
out there although we don't think any of
our next ones are appropriate Japanese
pregnant all you might want to close
your eyes because this is definitely a
sight a lot of children don't want to
see although it's definitely educational
to understand the process of childbirth
we have it feeling many kids would shake
their heads at this pregnant doll toy
which comes from Japan sure it's totally
realistic and complete with the
umbilical cord
but perhaps
goes a little bit too far we really
don't see how this would be an
interesting birthday present for anyone
oh Japan we love you but sometimes we
really don't understand your selection
of toys the cava kick kids like the
weirdest things and you'll often find
toys that will make you question why
would someone even buy this the kaabah
kick is one of those toys this
gun-shaped puncher is designed as a kid
version of the Russian Roulette and that
should be scary enough to tell you that
this is definitely not a kid-friendly
toy
of course this toy comes from Japan the
player points the toy gun at their head
and pulls the trigger
if you're lucky nothing will happen if
you're unlucky the gun will punch you in
the face sounds like fun right
that is until someone gets hurt Irwin
the little patients the name of the toy
sounds totally innocent but we're pretty
sure this urlan might give some kids a
few nightmares if you want to teach your
child some Anatomy you'll probably be
thrilled to hear about early in the
plush toy but we haven't feeling your
kid probably won't appreciate this
somewhat scary present Aran can be
opened up and you can pretty much pull
up every single part of his internal
organs to learn about the human body it
sounds good in theory but we're really
not sure how kids would feel about
having plush toys that look like
something pulled out of a stomach Bratz
doll and troll elephants speaking of
scary toys they're even scarier when
they're a pair the Bratz doll and the
troll elephant are a single toy bought
together we're not sure why and your
guess is as good as ours but what's even
stranger and possibly more disturbing
about this toy is that the elephant toy
trunk perfectly fits into the Bratz
dolls and mouth we're not sure if
there's a lesson to be taught somewhere
in there but if there is it'd probably
be that a child should stay away from
this questionable toy pair but nothing's
asked scary and questionable as the very
last toy that would make everyone
scratch their heads and possibly buy a
few life jackets to Titanic inflatable
slide this toy was actually so popular
it got unwanted attention and the slide
ended up getting banned yes you heard it
right this is an imitation of the actual
Titanic
in the shape of a water slide
can slide down it and imagine they're
sinking on the historical ship Titanic
already gives nightmares to many people
so we can't even imagine why would
anyone want to see what it's like to
slide down an inflatable sinking ship
for fun out of all the toys on our list
this one is definitely the one where we
have to pull the plug
sometimes it's definitely best of toys
stay in the toy makers imagination and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one check out 20 toys and no
kid would want to receive on Christmas
see you next time
[Music]